everybody in the world need to use
PowerPoint at some stage of their career
maybe due to Market analytics maybe they
have to use scientific presentation or
maybe they have to show some cool
business Analytics
but very few people know how to present
it well
and people don't know how to make
presentations more engaging to the
audience
let me give you a live example if a
teacher enters the class and try to
teach the
particular course in this way it would
be super boring for the audience right
and they would obviously sleep
what if we can change this boring text
Heavy PowerPoint slide into an engaging
one like this one
here you can see the informations are
conveyed step by step
in a PowerPoint slide deck
each of these informations are conveyed
sequentially in a precise and concise
manner
isn't it more engaging
so we launch a course which would teach
you how to make these kind of
presentations
and we have a very generous price for
that in this course you would learn how
to create this kind of engaging Graphics
in less than 10 minutes
he would learn to build Graphics from
scratch
in step-by-step fashion you would learn
how to create Dynamic Graphics like
these ones which are moving
and this would be super engaging for the
audience
obviously Dynamic animation would retain
your audience attention
you would also learn how to build up a
storyline precisely
and convey the information in a
streamlined fashion
then you would learn it all things about
transitions how transitions can help to
convey your message
and lastly we would teach you how to
build a great presentation what are the
things to keep in mind and what are the
nitty-gritty details you should keep in
mind while designing a presentation the
course has a dynamic interface
so you can scroll down and see all the
syllabus not only we provide detailed
lectures and step-by-step procedures by
which you can make the presentation you
can also see there are attachments and
workbooks for your overall practice
moreover we provide several templates
you can see you can download the
templates once you purchase the course
and don't forget to share with your
friends the course link is provided in
the description